but imagine seeing the park with fresh
eyes and every view a rare glimpse into
a hidden world just like this one a
[Music]
black bear and her cubs a typical litter
of three for five months she hasn't
stirred even as their mother slumbered
the Cubs nursed on a rich diet of super
fatty milk
over the winter her own weight dropped
up to 1/3
how she survived still stumps us during
hibernation
her heart rate fell to just eight beats
per minute that somehow she turned much
of her bodily waste into protein
in the coming months she must fatten up
on what the forest provides
the survival of the fragile Cubs depends
on their mother her survival depends on
the Smokies
after weeks confined to a cubbyhole new
life makes its debut in the park
black bears are born climbers with
strong claws even a bear cub negotiates
the trunk like a power lineman
their debut draws attention
[Music]
our mom must stay alert coyotes will
prey on the Cubs
so we'll Bobcats
[Music]
at night the treetops offer refuge from
predators that can't climb
in daylight on the ground the Cubs are
vulnerable so mom won't let them wander
for the next 18 months they'll shadow
their mother their instructor and
protector within a park that safeguards
them from another enemy man
[Music]
male Cubs will grow up to be loners like
they're long gone father
females will rear their own offspring
for now three wide-eyed toddlers enter a
world made for them if they learn to
make the most of it
[Music]
you